tu joues tes questions évidemment sinon
c'est pas drôle non là c'est homophobe
c'est pas grave pourquoi
bien sûr tu écrases des [__]
pas du tout bien sûr il est écrasait de
[__] c'est parce que j'avais vu ben
arrête
de mecs très proches pour faire ce truc
rapprochez-vous ok c'est bon je te
kiffais ça il doit y avoir forcément des
gars conduit essayer ça pour rigoler
quand tu as deux [__] ça doit être
vraiment un moment ça devient à l'idée
c'est le mot trop quoi
faire des trucs
ça va c'est tout va bien
oh mais j'ai tellement l'image [__]
bonjour bonjour
[Rires]
cette année ricardie vous êtes juré du
TikTok Film Festival grosse
responsabilité juré tous les artistes
qu'on voyait leur film forcément que ce
soit Tik Tok ou un autre festival c'est
c'est une étape importante pour ce qui
gagne ils viennent ici quoi ils sont
invités ici et par Tic-Toc oui c'est pas
le titre le festival TikTok à Cambrai
quelque chose contre quoi pourquoi c'est
pas sympa parce qu'il y a des gens qui
habitent cette vie il faut toujours que
tu dénigres quelqu'un pour encenser
quelqu'un d'autre continue d'enfoncer
quelqu'un qui sait pas s'en sortir tu
sais ce que j'ai mal pris c'est qu'au
début ils l'ont demandé ils ont proposé
46 ah bon en même temps ça dit quelque
chose de votre duo peut-être que ça
faisait plus important peut-être que je
regarde mieux les petits films d'une
minute à quoi est-ce que vous êtes
sensible quand vous regardez un film si
ça me procure rien et que soudain je
décroche et de l'histoire et du jeu pour
ne voir que les figures en derrière ou
un décor un peu foireux c'est que ben
j'ai pas été ému moi c'est tout
l'inverse je regarde que les décors que
les figurants l'émotion ça c'est un
producteur
une bonne question qu'est-ce qui vous
fait pleurer tous les deux le cinéma la
tolérance
la justice qu'est-ce qui vous fait rire
au cinéma la bêtise ouais c'est vrai que
la bêtise on a construit un peu nous
notre humour là-dessus sur le débile
quoi c'est Mitterrand qui disait le rire
et le repos de l'intelligence BIM et
qu'est-ce qui vous fait jouir Mitterrand
Mitterrand aussi mais dans des news
et quel genre de juriste que vous allez
être vous êtes corruptibles ou pas
largement correctile moi je pense que
s'il m'avait donné vraiment de l'argent
pour pour favoriser un film je l'aurais
pris vous vous dites tout tous les deux
non vous mentez
on se cache des choses je pense toi tu
m'as menti moi je t'ai menti et on
t'aimant honteusement sur quoi de au
truc de Squeezie ah non mais ça n'a rien
à voir ça quand même c'était quand même
quelque chose vraiment oui parce que oui
vraiment j'en ai un peu touché je fumais
un peu ben je m'excuse je suis accepté
ça fait 30 ans que vous vous connaissez
qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit vous
souvenez la première fois que vous êtes
vu moi je me rappelle la première phrase
c'est attend un coup de fil de quilles
avec ce à 3h du matin c'était l'époque
où les portables c'était il y en avait
pas c'était c'est des grosses briques
avec une antenne non non même avant
c'est les premiers gros truc Philips
avec une valise donc il y avait très peu
de gens avec eux des chefs d'entreprise
qui avait ça moi j'en avais trouvé
et puis ça a rien à voir vraiment et si
vous deviez faire une interview
Eric de Ramzy par exemple quelle est la
première question que vous lui poseriez
je t'ai manqué
c'est une question c'est une affirmation
c'est une question ah je t'ai manqué
et moi ma question j'avais déjà faut
répondre ah oui
c'est pas hyper non mais c'était un peu
émouvant là
surtout que ça répond pas ouais je peux
pas mettre plus d'émotions dedans pas
hyper enthousiasme la réponse est pas
satisfait je dirais oui ça va tu me
remplacer quoi non non oui non si je
t'avais remplacé tu m'aurais pas manqué
tu ne manquerais pas si je peux te
moquer c'est toi qui m'a remplacé avec
Hafid et c'est toi qui m'a remplacer les
Gaston bide
première question à Éric est ce que tu
te marres autant sur moi
non non c'est un rire différent si j'ai
un rire différent
on passe dans une autre sphère avec toi
c'est pas le même non quelle est la
meilleure question que vous avez jamais
posée alors ça par exemple c'est une
question nulle non moi j'ai bien aimé ta
question précédente la question
précédente dans laquelle si vous
interviewez qui est très la première
question que vous lui poseriez j'ai aimé
cette question
celle-là voulait mais moi elle était
nulle
et tu te rends pas compte du talent que
tu as avec la question de la vente qui
était fabuleuse